we choose to go to the moon in this  decade and do the other things not  because they are easy but because they  are hard this is setting us back for  years we can't land on the moon we  aren't touching down for five years  gender Stan what this means NASA can't  do it they can't land man and come back  we can make a film that shows us going  to the moon without actually doing it  cupric is getting NASA to make sure that  his space movie looks like real space  and so we're gonna use his face movie to  make sure the real space movie looks  like space they said how crazy that is  you don't have an ethical problem with  this at all  this is like one of those good lies like  Santa Claus and the Easter Bunny you are  be the paranoid if they point out what  we're doing then you're dead and your  pictures fenestration before yeah I  think we're in  so happy early I imagine that's not  exactly true  doctor this is Lee weathers or corporate  I'm just looking for some information  about Morgan